BRENNAN: Hello, everyone. Good morning. I
wanted to thank everyone for coming here today.
It is a great way to start off your morning,
and hopefully we'll have a great conversation.
We're going to have some remarks from the
senator here.
Before we get underway, I want to remind everyone
that the conversation is on the record. It
is being broadcast as well, and we will give
you all a chance – hopefully all – to
ask some questions after we finish the question
and answer period up here -- we'll have some
microphones for you. I'm sure you've all seen
these and been to these before, so you're
old hands at that.
But this is, of course, Angus King, who's
going to give us a sense of why he wants to
talk right now about Iran, this nuclear deal
that has been signed, and his concern about
implementation and follow through – some
challenges to it.
I'm Margaret Brennan from CBS News – I'm
also a term member here at the Council on
Foreign Relations. So I am excited to be doing
this conversation – my first one as a member.
But I cover foreign policy for CBS News and
national security, so you'll see me on the
road often in places like Geneva, with deals
like this being negotiated.
But without further ado, just to introduce
the conversation once again, I want to ask
the senator to give us a sense of his thoughts,
and why we're here today. Angus King, of course,
an independent from Maine, on armed services,
on intelligence, and has a lot to say about
this.
KING: Great. Thanks, Margaret.
Margaret didn't tell you, but she just got
back from Geneva, so I appreciate your joining
us today.
What I'd like to do, before we get to, hopefully,
a lot of questions -- and this is a story
that's changing by the day -- is first start
with a little bit about who am I, since this
is my first visit with this -- with this group.
The first thing, in terms of where we are,
is that my home town is Alexandria, Virginia.
Although I'm a senator from Maine, I grew
up in Alexandria. My granddad was the mayor
of Alexandria in the '20s. And I went to Maine
in 1969 out of Virginia Law School to join
Lyndon Johnson's War on Poverty. I was with
the -- remember -- some of you remember the
OEO and the Legal Services Corporation, and
I was assigned to Maine.
Being from Virginia, when I got to Maine,
I had a son born in 1970 in the Skowhegan,
Maine, hospital, and I learned at that time
how hard it is to be from Maine because after
my son was born, I was so excited, I went
out on the street and said, Oh -- I ran into
an old farmer friend of mine, Charles Forbus
(ph). I said, Mr. Forbus (ph), guess what?
I have a son just born in the Skowhegan hospital!
He's a native of Maine!
And the old farmer looked at me over his glasses
and says, Well, by gorry (ph), just because
the cat has her kittens in the oven don't
make 'em biscuits.
(LAUGHTER)
So I'd learned at that moment that you can't
be from Maine even if you've been born there.
Went to Dartmouth College -- by the way, there
are four senators from Dartmouth in the United
States Senate right now, I think the largest
delegation from any one college -- Rob Portman,
Kirsten Gillibrand, John Hoeven and myself.
University of Virginia Law School -- we have
three senators from Virginia Law School, Sheldon
Whitehouse and Bill Nelson, who was there
when I was. Then went to Maine, as I said,
worked for Pinetree Legal Assistance in rural
Maine.
Then had an interesting experience. This is
relevant to what I'm doing now. I came back
to Washington for two-and-a-half years and
worked as a staff member in the U.S. Senate.
I was sworn in as a United States senator
40 years to the day from the day I entered
service as a staff member of the Senate in
January of 1973. So that's a rich area of
discussion in itself, is what the Senate -- how
the Senate and the Congress has changed during
that period. It's really fascinating.
For example, I remember going to conference
committees pretty regularly in those days.
Now a conference committee -- I think there
were two or maybe three in the last year.
Practiced law in Maine, went into business,
was in the renewable energy business really
for most of my adult life -- hydropower, biomass,
energy conservation, wind power -- and spent
a lot of time in the energy business. And
then was governor of Maine for eight years
in the '90s and into 2002 as an independent.
And then retired from politics, taught at
Bowdoin and Bates Colleges, worked on some
boards, did a variety of things, had no intention
or expectation of ever getting back into politics
or ever running for anything. And then in
February of 2012, Olympia Snowe, to everyone's
shock and surprise, announced her retirement,
basically because, she said, I'm just sick
and tired of the Senate and the Congress not
working.
And I thought, Well, maybe I can make a contribution
as an independent and try to make the institution
work a little bit better. So that was the
-- that was the beginning of my reentry into
politics in the spring of 2012. I was elected
in November of 2012 and started in the Senate
last year as the world's oldest freshman and
was appointed -- of course, you know, I -- first,
my intention was to be a pure independent.
Chris Matthews -- I was on "Hardball." Chris
said -- by the way, if you're ever -- when
you're with Chris, he interviews himself,
really.
(LAUGHTER)
And you're there -- you're sort of the wallpaper.
But he said, Angus, why don't you just put
your chair in the middle and be a real independent?
Don't join any party's caucus and everything.
Well, that was fine until I found out you
don't get committee assignments except through
the caucus.
So I joined the Democratic caucus and was
appointed to Armed Services, Rules, Budget,
and to prove Harry Reid has a sense of humor,
Intelligence. And those are the committees,
ironically, when ended up putting me right
in the center of everything that went on last
year. Syria, the budget, Iran, NSA, Snowden
-- all of those issues, I've been up to my
elbows in right from the very beginning.
And that brings us to today, which -- I wanted
to talk for a few minutes about Iran. The
story is changing literally as we sit here.
This morning, there's a Reuters report that
the advocates for the new sanctions bill have
now -- are talking about backing off and having
another kind of bill but not necessarily new
sanctions. So all my carefully written objections
to why we shouldn't do sanctions may be moot
as of this morning.
But I want to talk generally about the situation
and about the sanctions bill because, you
know, things can change on a sort of day-to-day
basis. Just before the break last week, I
talked to one of the senior senators about
this issue, and his comment was, Well, we
may back off, but if the Iranian economy improves
over the next six months, then we'll be back.
That was sort of his standard for what was
going on.
So I think it's a very fluid situation. As
you know, 59 senators sponsored S-1881, or
co-sponsored it, which was the sort of the
new sanctions bill sponsored by Senator Menendez.
And there was a report over the weekend that
they felt they had 75 votes if it actually
came to the floor, which would have made it
veto-proof.
A similar bill passed the House last summer
before the announcement of the interim agreement,
so that's a different kind of situation. But
still, I don't think there's any doubt that
there's substantial interest in this issue
and a substantial interest in the possibility
of additional sanctions.
You all know -- you all know the issue. The
basic issue is what's -- what's Congress's
role in this process while negotiations are
under way with regard to Iran? And I'm going
to walk through that, although I -- it's a
funny situation. I developed this position
thinking about this issue, talking to people
like Carl Levin and Dianne Feinstein and others
who I really respect on these kinds of issues
back in December.
And at the time, my position, which was opposed
to the bill -- I was an outlier and a contrarian
because all the momentum was in the direction
of -- of the sanctions. And then over the
course of the last several weeks, the momentum
seems to have shifted, and the push for new
sanctions, as I mentioned, even as recently
as this morning seems to have diminished.
I feel good about that. I don't take responsibility
for it, but I can tell you that I and others
talked to other members of various caucuses
about this issue. And I have to say I think
one of the key moments was a week ago, on
a Thursday, when the Democratic caucus went
to the White House to meet with the president,
closed-door meeting, no press. There was very
little staff there. And it was a -- there
were a variety of issues. It wasn't -- there
wasn't any agenda, and the president was talking
about the minimum wage and the economy, middle
class, and all that.
And one of the senators asked him about Iran,
and he gave -- he was the most powerful and
persuasive I have ever seen him on any subject,
on why it would be a mistake to move forward
with additional sanctions or even additional
sanctions triggered later, as were proposed
by the Menendez bill.
I mean, I sat there and thought I don't know
how anybody can sit in this room and feel
that this is the right course, given his really
eloquent -- no notes, no teleprompter, no
anything, just sitting on a stool -- a really
powerful statement about, you know, the history
of how we got here and what we should do.
And I think that probably had something to
do with some of the steam coming out of this
issue, not that people were saying, We've
got to do this because we've got to be loyal
to the president, but I think because he was
just downright persuasive. And I think that
was -- that does occasionally happen around
here, and I think this was a case where it
did.
But I feel a little funny because I took a
position and the world changed, I still have
the same position. Some of you remember Mort
Sahl from the '50s, the comedian. Mort Sahl
once said if you maintain a consistent political
opinion in this country long enough, you will
eventually be tried for treason. And you know,
I sort of felt like I stayed the same and
everything sort of -- sort of shifted.
Some important things about the sanctions.
We've had sanctions against Iran since 1979,
in one way, shape or form. But the sanctions
that have really bitten, the sanctions that
have really changed the face of the Iranian
economy are those that went into effect around
2009, 2010 and involved the rest of the world.
Iranian oil exports have gone from 2.5 million
barrels a day to 1. That's about a 60 percent
reduction. A hundred percent of that reduction
is because of reduced purchases by other countries,
not by the U.S. The EU reduced their purchases
600,000 barrels a day -- China, Japan, India.
So it's really important to realize that the
sanctions that are biting are the international
coalition sanctions, not simply U.S. sanctions.
Now, we've provoked a lot of those by pressure
on our allies. There's no question that we've
led it. But I think it's really important
to realize that unilateral sanctions from
the U.S. aren't necessarily going to be the
way to change Iranian policy.
The results have really been significant.
I mentioned the oil -- $100 billion to $30
billion of revenue in -- in oil revenue, 50
percent inflation, 20 percent unemployment,
5 percent contraction last year in the Iranian
GDP. This is -- this is the effect that it's
had, and it's really been significant.
And as you know, a new president was elected,
and the platform that he had was economic
improvement. Sounds familiar. I mean, you
run for president, you say, We're going to
have more jobs, the economy's going to improve.
But he came to the realization that the sanctions
were a significant part of the problem, and
he had a more open attitude toward trying
to -- to modify them.
So where are we? You all know. We've got a
six-month interim agreement with some very
significant -- I reread it this morning. There's
a good summary on WhiteHouse.gov. If you do
WhiteHouse.gov summary of sanctions, you've
got the whole long list of -- of what they
have to do and what we do in terms of the
-- the giving up of the -- easing up on about
$7 billion worth of value over the six months.
And it's a pretty impressive piece of negotiation.
The value isn't all given on day one. It's
parceled out over a period of time. And the
sanctions -- the changes in the imposition
on the Iranian nuclear program are really
quite significant, talk about dilution of
the 20 percent enriched, no more -- no more
5 percent enriched, restrictions on the Arak
reactor, a lot of other detailed restrictions.
But probably more importantly, extraordinary
new transparency and access. And that's the
key part of this, more than we've ever had
before.
And the real question is, Will it -- will
they do it? And because this is a project
that is in at least two steps -- maybe more,
but at least two steps, we have an opportunity
to test the Iranians' good faith, to test
whether they are, in fact, going to live up
to the commitments made in this interim agreement.
And the terms of the interim agreement really
cause a pause in their ability to reach breakout
in terms of a nuclear weapon. So it -- it's
a pretty solid piece of work in terms of the
effects on the Iranians, and particularly
the transparency to see whether they're honoring
the commitment.
It also is worth mentioning that the oil sanctions
don't change, that that's not part of the
deal. The sanctions that have limited the
sale of oil are exactly the same. There's
not -- no opening up.
Now, the proponents for the bill, S-1881,
make a plausible case. If sanctions have gotten
us this far, won't more sanctions get us further?
If you strengthen the sanctions, it'll strengthen
the president's hand. It'll give him a stronger
had to negotiation and we'll have a stronger
agreement at the end.
You know, that -- that makes sense. We'll
get a better deal. And besides, we can't trust
the Iranians. And you know, Reagan said "Trust
but verify." I think, in this case, it's verify
but verify. I mean, there's a lot of history
here, and I think -- I don't think trust really
is necessarily part of the equation. It has
to be verify and verify.
And I want to pause right now, just -- my
notes say "humility." Nobody knows how these
things are going to play out. Nobody knows
what's going to happen over the next six months
or over the next couple of years. It's a very
unpredictable situation.
So I'm standing here with great assurance,
giving you my position, but I don't guarantee
being right. And I don't think anybody can
take that position. I think when you're talking
about foreign policy, humility is an important
quality, to realize the challenges of predicting,
particularly when you're predicting what another
country and another culture, another political
system is going to do.
But the argument is, Let's strengthen the
president's hand. Let's get a better deal.
I don't -- I just don't think that works.
And I think the Congress -- and maybe this
is old news as of this morning, but the idea
of imposing new sanctions now I think is just
-- is not -- not useful. And I think it would
have exactly the opposite effect of that which
is desired.
One effect might well be the Iranians just
plain walk, that the hard-liners -- I mean,
I -- we -- I wrote a little piece with Carl
Levin, and we said that would -- that theory
would work if Iran was a politics-free zone.
But Iran has internal politics, just like
the U.S. or Great Britain or Germany or anywhere
else, and there are people in Iran who don't
like these conversations. They don't want
to give up any part of the nuclear program.
They -- they are very reluctant to give up
what they consider something important to
their national pride and perhaps national
survival.
So if we change the goalposts, if we say,
We're going to, by the way, put in new sanctions
-- and by the way, the interim agreement has
a specific provision that says, No new sanctions.
So we would be in violation of that interim
agreement, if we imposed new sanctions. It
could be argued, Well, it's they trigger six
months. Does that count? I'm not sure that
-- that subtlety would translate very well
into Farsi.
The headline in Tehran would be, U.S. Congress
imposes new sanctions. And my concern is that
would empower the hardliners to say, I told
you so. You can't trust the Americans. We're
walking away from this. And this is the best
chance we've had in a decade or more to do
something about this very serious issue of
Iran -- of Iran having nuclear weapons.
So I worry about the hard-liners, even with
a delayed trigger, and that it would undercut
Rouhani and take away his ability to make
a deal. He's got -- he's got to play to his
political base, and of course, the Supreme
Leader in Iran has immense input on this.
The second reason I think it's a bad idea
is that, again, to go back to what I mentioned,
this -- these sanctions work because of the
support of the international community. And
if we impose new sanctions and the international
-- the coalition, the partners that are involved
in the sanctions say, Well, that -- we wanted
this interim agreement, it tends to weaken
their support for the sanctions, which, ironically,
could end up leading to weaker sanctions in
the end. We would end up worse than we started
off because the real power of the sanctions
comes from the support of the international
community.
I think Congress has an important role. I
think Congress has an important role being
the sword in the sheath, if you will. But
you don't have to -- you don't have the bare
the sword. Everybody knows that Iranians know
that Congress is ready to impose new sanctions,
is discussing it, is actively thinking about
it.
But if they pass it and then the president
has to veto it, it just -- I think it makes
a very difficult situation for our negotiators,
and the Iranians say, Well, who does speak
for the U.S. government? We have this agreement
that went into effect last week, but it's
been abrogated, you know, two weeks later.
Who are we negotiating with here? Maybe we
should -- instead of talking to the president
or the secretary of state, we should talk
to Harry Reid and Bob Menendez or John Boehner.
I mean, I think it raises a legitimate question
about who speaks for the United States. So
I think Congress has an important role, but
I don't think it's to -- it's to come in and
raise a question about who speaks for the
-- for the United States government.
I think, finally, this is a pretty simple
question of risk analysis, for me. What's
the up side and what's the down side? I see
very little up side to passing a bill of this
nature now. It may strengthen the president's
hand, maybe. That's the possible up side.
But the down side I view as enormous. If they
walk, if the talks end, if the sanction coalition
falls apart, that's -- we may have missed
a once-in-a-generation opportunity to deal
with this problem.
And the final point is, there aren't many
options to deal with the problem of a potentially
nuclear-armed Iran. One is negotiation and
the other is military action. The third, I
suppose, is to tolerate a military -- a nuclear-armed
Iran, but nobody seems to want to consider
that as an option, and I don't think it should
be. But that leaves military force.
And you know, maybe negotiations could start
again under different circumstances and we
could tighten the noose of sanctions, but
we've got this opportunity in front of us.
The agreements in the interim agreement are
pretty significant. They're not token. And
we have an opportunity to test the Iranians'
good faith, to test their ability to allow
access, to test their ability to actually
take concrete steps to step away from nuclear
arms. And I don't see much down side, particularly
since there's a pause in their development
of capability to break out, to allowing this
process to play out over the next six to twelve
months.
There are going to be ups and downs. There's
going to be posturing on both sides. There's
going to be difficult negotiations. And of
course, the ultimate question will be, What
does the final deal look like? And does it
-- is it something that we really want to
-- is it good enough to satisfy us and our
allies that we've prevented this -- the nuclear
armament of Iran. But that's going to be part
of the discussion over the next six months.
So my view is, as I certainly made clear,
that we have an opportunity here and we shouldn't
let it slip away. Ronald Reagan said a very
interesting thing. He said, Peace is not the
absence of conflict. There will always be
conflict in the world. But peace is the ability
to cope with conflict by peaceful means. And
I think we're in a moment now where we have
an opportunity to cope with conflict by peaceable
means. And I certainly hope that we seize
it, and I hope that the Congress is able to
play a constructive role in this process.
So that's -- I hope I've given you some food
for thought, and now we'll have a conversation.
Thank you very much for giving me this opportunity.
(APPLAUSE)
BRENNAN: Senator, I should have led with you
went to University of Virginia Law school.
KING: Yes.
BRENNAN: Because I'm a UVA grad...
(CROSSTALK)
KING: Good for you.
BRENNAN: Key element there in your bio.
I want to follow up on some of what you're
talking about. Just to clarify, sounds like
what you believe, momentum is slowing on the
Hill in terms of this threat to impose new
sanctions. Is this bill really on ice?
KING: Well, things change day to day, but
I would say, based on the story this morning,
based on comments I'm getting on the floor,
the momentum has slowed in terms of bringing
it forward. I don't see the sponsors withdrawing
it or anything like that. My guess is -- but
-- and you know, we're all going -- literally,
this was a Reuters report this morning that
a new version is being drafted that doesn't
necessarily involve new sanctions, but will
involve some language, you know, keeping the
pressure on the administration.
So if I had to bet right now, I would think
that it probably won't come to the floor any
time soon, but I don't have that directly
from Harry Reid, but that's my impression.
BRENNAN: You talked about a change leading
to this probably happening around last week.
Last week's also when this deal went into
effect, last Monday. To a certain extent -- maybe
this is a cynical view or a cynical posture
to pose here.
KING: A member of the press cynical?
BRENNAN: I'm a paid cynic. So when you look
at the timing here, hasn't Congress's role
really been tactical pressure for the administration
because these technical details have been
worked out in the past few weeks before the
agreement went into effect on Monday?
KING: I think the pressure has helped, for
sure. Somebody said that this is a bill that's
better threatened than passed. And I think,
to some extent, that was the case.
The momentum started to change, I think, when
people like Dianne Feinstein went to the floor
and made a very strong speech against it,
Carl Levin, who's, you know, been very strong
on Iran and these issues, and then some of
the people in this audience who've made statements,
Jessica Matthews's story in The New York Review
of Books.
I think a lot of people have been sort of
saying, Wait a minute. Slow down. What would
be the effect here? Because it -- at the beginning,
it was, you know, Let's go and -- and you
know, they got 59 co-sponsors in a matter
of weeks, and then it kind of stopped.
BRENNAN: So you're on the Intelligence Committee.
You've received briefings on what's actually
in this deal. Does this extend Iran's breakout
time, the time it takes for them to actually
build a weapon?
KING: I've got to be really careful and remember
what I know in what context and what I can
talk about. But I think it's public knowledge
that the terms that -- that caused the dilution
of the 20 percent enriched, the freezing of
the 5 percent, in effect, the freezing of
the construction of the Arak reactor does
delay the breakout time to some extent.
The other piece of intelligence -- and I've
seen both classified and unclassified, but
the unclassified is the intelligence community
does believe that additional sanctions now
would -- there's a -- can't remember if moderate
-- high likelihood that the Iranians would
walk. So there's an intelligence basis for
-- for that concern, because of internal politics
of -- in Iran.
BRENNAN: One of the other things you talked
about in your remarks there was not just the
Iranians walking but part of the alliance
breaking up. Is that code for Russia would
walk, Russia would start violating these sanctions,
China would?
KING: That isn't -- that wasn't my intention.
I don't know -- there -- I don't know who
might break off, but it's not -- I think there's
some fragility, and I don't know who it would
be, but some of these countries that are backing
off of their purchases, it's at some cost
to them. It isn't something that they were
thrilled to do. And so you know, I don't know
whether -- I couldn't say whether -- Russia
is less a player on the oil front because
they don't purchase much oil. The EU and China
and India are the biggest that changed that
equation.
The other piece -- and Mr. Pollack -- what's
his first name?
BRENNAN: Ken?
KING: Ken Pollack wrote a good piece that,
in a sense, we have the high ground now. You
know, we're negotiating, and if there's a
breach, it's on the Iranians. If we flip that
and impose new sanctions in violation of the
interim agreement, we lose the high ground
and we -- and it gives our partners more of
a chance to walk. He argues that the most
powerful reason not to do this is the breakup
of the coalition.
BRENNAN: So with these six months, that time
that's been purchased, essentially, you say
that has expanded the breakout time -- what's
gained over that? What happens at the end
of the six months?
KING: Well, that's going to be a big question,
and I think one of the questions that has
to be considered is what -- what is success?
What's the definition of success? Some of
our allies want success to be no nuclear capacity
at all, no enrichment capacity at all.
The indications from Iran is that they're
not going to accept that. So the question
is what between zero and something is going
to be acceptable in the agreement, and there
are going to be all kinds of other pieces
to it in terms of reactors and centrifuges
and parts and inspections and all those kinds
of things.
There's no certainty here. My position is
that we -- if we -- if we can have a pause,
a slowdown of the breakout period, and an
opportunity, a chance to get a deal, we ought
to take it because the other options are very
unattractive. And the -- the consensus seems
to be that if military force was used, the
best we could do is delay it. We couldn't
necessarily eliminate the capacity, and if
we delay it, then we're back in the same box
at some period.
Plus, if -- if we -- if there are air strikes,
whoever does them, it seems to me the chances
that they would then forswear the development
of nuclear weapons go close to zero. They're
going to say, We've got to have them. These
people are bombing us. And so we've accelerated
that intention.
And right now, it's an open question. The
intelligence is unclear as to what the Supreme
Leader really wants to do here. There -- he's
made statements in the past saying this is
inconsistent -- nuclear weapons are inconsistent
with Islamic law.
So I think, you know, in any kind of situation
like this, where you're making decisions,
you've got to say, Compared to what? And right
now, we've got a promising opportunity and
compared to what, meaning bombing, delay,
almost assured pursuit of a weapon after that
-- to me, it's a good time to take a deep
breath and let it play out.
BRENNAN: And when you were talking about breakout
time, you're talking about the capacity to
build a weapon, or the ability to weaponize?
So there seems to be two different definitions
there.
KING: Well, I think it's capacity. I -- I
take a fairly conservative view on that, and
that if you -- if they have the -- if they
have the capacity to do it in a reasonably
short period of time, that's pretty close
to being able to do it, and that we really
need to be looking for an agreement that limits
that capacity.
BRENNAN: And so in these negotiations, you
think that -- that definition of breakout's
been extended. By how much?
KING: I couldn't say. Months? I think, as
I view it -- and again, there are probably
people in this room who are more expert than
I am on this. But as I view the interim agreement,
it delays breakout by the period of the agreement.
BRENNAN: About six months.
KING: And -- but it could be two months either
way. But I don't think -- and I think this
is a legitimate question, is, is all this
talk just to get a delay to go toward breakout?
You know, are we -- is it all just a sham?
And the provisions of the interim agreement
I think are real and I think do have an effect,
assuming they're -- they're done. I mean,
I think that's a big part of this is, is it
going to be effectuated? Is it going to be
implemented? Are they going to meet their
commitments? And do they allow the kind of
access that they're talking about, daily access
instead of every two weeks, and you know,
instantaneous monitoring? If all of those
things occur and we can verify, you know,
I think we're not -- we're not losing anything
by providing this time.
Now, you know, events could prove us -- could
prove me and others totally wrong, and there
may be a lab under a mountain somewhere that
nobody knows about that, you know, is working
away at it. But given the facts as we know
it now, I think we need to take this time.
BRENNAN: And what level of transparency is
there with the Hill right now, with people
on the committees you sit on, in terms of
that follow-through? How regular will you...
(CROSSTALK)
KING: There are some Intelligence hearing
tomorrow on the -- it's the -- it's the annual
worldwide threat assessment, which I know
this is going to be a major thrust. It's an
open hearing. So we will talk about that,
undoubtedly. And I talked to Chairman Feinstein
about this. There are going to be closed hearings
on Iran, so we have a full briefing on what
-- what we know, how we know it, and how transparent
the process is.
And I think that's one of the most important
responsibilities that we have is to be sure
that that's the case, that it's not wishful
thinking, that we're not just hoping that
they're doing it because as far as I'm concerned,
if it's not verifiable, then, you know, doesn't
count. That's got to be a place where I think
Congress keeps its thumb on the administration.
And as I mentioned, there's a -- Congress
has a role here. It's just a question of how
overt the role is. But I think the pressure
on the administration is important. The pressure
for verification is important. And you know,
we're going to be continuing to ask the questions.
BRENNAN: I do want to get to some questions
from the audience. One more before I do that,
and that is -- and this is more of a policy
question. I do want to -- as to your personal
views, but do you think any of this actually
leads to empowering the moderates in a way,
the relative moderates in Iran, that could,
in theory, lead to a grand bargain? Is there
something more to be gained, or are we purely...
KING: Grand bargain? I thought that was with
Boehner.
(LAUGHTER)
KING: I know what you mean.
BRENNAN: On Syria and other issues that are
also of concern to the administration.
KING: I wish I could say yes. I -- I don't
see this link to Syria. I think Syria's a
separate issue. You were just there. Syria's
the most complex public policy issue I've
ever looked at, with the possible exception
of health care. So I don't think there's necessarily
a linkage there.
I do think -- you know, Iran is an ancient
civilization, a pretty modern country, and
you know, we've been estranged from them since
'79 and no -- there's not going to be a normalization
of relations overnight by any means, but this
could be a step toward opening up of that
country somewhat more to the West and a moderation
of their politics. But I don't -- I don't
see, you know, regime change any time soon
there, and that's an unrealistic expectation.
BRENNAN: Well, I do want to get to the audience
now. We have microphones. If you would just
say your name and affiliation and stand up.
KING: Somebody's going to...
(CROSSTALK)
BRENNAN: ... front row.
QUESTION: Thank you. Morning. Richard Downey
(ph) from Delphi Strategic Consulting. And
thank you very much for interesting comments
and discussion.
I wanted to ask you to clarify something you
just touched on briefly. You mentioned that
the success of the sanctions was really due,
after 2009, 2010, to the -- the international
community really following through on this.
And you also mentioned that the -- it's all
about verifying. Trust doesn't really work,
that we really have to ensure that the Iranians
follow through on what they've promised.
But when you addressed the Kenneth Pollack
article, you just sort of glanced by -- I
wonder, do you believe that as we move through
this process that the -- that the international
community will weaken its -- its strength
in terms of focusing on this? And can we -- can
we gather that same kind of power in sanctions
later on, if the Iranians do renege on what
they promised to do?
KING: That's a very good question, and I think
there is concern that the -- that opening
-- opening the door to the easing of the sanctions
can create a slippery slope and we're -- it's
going to be very hard to put it back together.
I think if you focus, though, on what exactly
the opening of the door is, it's pretty limited.
It's not a change in the -- in the oil limitations,
for example. It's -- it's -- of the $7 billion
of sanctions relief, $4.5 billion or $4.2
billion is the freeing up of Iranian frozen
assets that -- you know, that they -- from
their oil from previous years. So it's not
that there's this huge opening, although I
have heard that there's a lot of interest
in Teheran, there are a lot of foreign companies
that are trying to get ready to do business,
and those kinds of things. And I think that's
something that we have to keep an eye on.
But if we -- it seems -- the question is,
what makes the international coalition sticking
together more or less likely? My sense is
that us imposing additional sanctions now
in violation of the interim agreement, that
they, after all, helped negotiate, would undermine
that more than the modest reductions in the
sanctions that are going to go over the six
months. I mean, that's -- that's a -- that's
a judgment call.
And I think it's a legitimate question, but
their commitment, I think, rests at least
in part on their view that, Hey, we did what
you wanted us to do. It's had the effect you
wanted. We got to the table. They're making
some movement. Let's keep going. That -- that
-- you know, and it -- you know, and it's
-- I can't speak for the Chinese or the Japanese
and what their motivations are, but that's
my sense, is that it's more likely to hold
if we honor the interim agreement than the
contrary.
BRENNAN: But to follow on that, I mean, in
Davos last week, we were standing there with
Secretary Kerry, and on another stage, Rouhani
standing up there saying Iran's open for business.
Come look at what we got. Come see our oil
fields. That's a bet that six months from
now, there's going to be an ability to invest
or that there are enough cracks to the regime
to allow for it.
KING: Well, listen, I want them to be motivated
to make a good deal. I mean, that's -- I mean,
you got to declare -- sometimes, you got to
declare victory. I mean, if we get a solid,
verifiable deal that solves this problem,
then we've achieved what we wanted to achieve.
The purpose of the sanctions was to keep Iran
from getting a nuclear weapon, and that should
be the -- that's the goal.
BRENNAN: On this side of the room, do we have
questions? And here in the middle, can we
run a mic , second row.
KING: Don't have to only talk about Iran,
by the way. If you want to talk about the
farm bill, I can do that, too.
QUESTION: As a fellow property tax payer and
neighbor in the town of Brunswick...
KING: Hey!
QUESTION: ... I just want to welcome you to
(inaudible)
KING: You're a great American.
QUESTION: ... to the council.
(LAUGHTER)
QUESTION: Gordon Adams (ph), American University.
Couple of quickies. One is, you -- I wonder
what the advantage -- this seems to be a very
strong moment that your remarks suggest here,
where both sides in this negotiation actually
are playing good cop/bad cop. On both sides
of this, there is, Watch out for these conservatives
behind me be because they're going to derail
this agreement if you give them half an opening.
On our side, watch out for these folks over
here with sanctions in the Senate because
they're going to derail this negotiation.
Does that make it more propitious or less
propitious to actually get a deal? There's
a curious symmetry there.
The other question was, I wanted to push back
a little bit on the question of other issues
because there is this broader agenda with
Iran, which is support for terrorism and meddling
in Syria and meddling in Iraq and other issues
that are of importance to us.
Could you be -- give us just a little bit
more on why you think it makes sense to sort
this piece out separately from that broader
discussion.
KING: I didn't -- I didn't mean to imply that
it should be sorted out. I just -- I think
what I -- I hope what I communicated was that
I'm not sure we're going to be able to join
them. There's a difference. I'm not saying
we should explicitly -- if we can settle some
of these other issues and do something about,
you know, Hezbollah and Hamas and -- and support
for Syria, all the better, and the other -- export
of terrorism and those kinds of things.
That -- that would be a great result. I'm
just not sure that that's achievable, given
the scope of what's being discussed. Might
be possible. Part of that is going to depend
upon how the international partners feel about
those other issues and whether they're willing
to stick with some level of sanctions in order
to achieve a larger -- a larger result.
Your comment about both sides have the -- I
liken it to a used car deal, where there's
always a guy upstairs. You know, you negotiate
with the salesman, and he says, Well, I'm
not sure. I've got to check with the guy upstairs.
I've never been sure whether that person really
exists. But that's a -- that's a common function
in any negotiation.
And I think, clearly, the president's hand
is strengthened by the fact that Congress
is -- is behind the curtain here, and everybody
knows that they're prepared to move forward,
for example, if the -- the deal doesn't get
to the proper place, there's a lack of verification,
I can tell you it's not going to take long
for -- for that bill to come to the floor.
I mean, if Harry Reid says it's coming to
the floor, it's going to come to the floor
and it's going to get its -- going to get,
you know, solid support.
But -- so I do think that the people in the
background do have an important role to play.
I often have thought -- going back, you know,
to Vietnam and -- and you know, foreign policy
in the last 50 years, one of the fundamental
mistakes we as Americans make is to assume
that everybody else in the world thinks like
we do, that they -- and they -- and they don't.
They have different cultures. They have different
values.
And you know, I can remember in college hearing
speeches from the Bundys about this rational
policy on Vietnam and how we were going to
squeeze them and ratchet it up, and they were
going to have to give in. And I remember George
Mitchell talking about Saddam and he was going
to have to give in because his economy shrunk
by .2 percent. That -- it just doesn't necessarily
work that way.
And so I think we have to understand and try
to put ourselves into the shoes of this other
society in terms of what -- you know, what's
going to be -- what's going to be possible.
But you know, this moment of a nuclear Iran
-- and one of the -- Jessica Matthews (ph)
makes the point that usually, when one country
in a region goes nuclear, it -- they do it
in clumps. And if Iran develops a weapon,
Saudi Arabia and Turkey and perhaps Egypt
are going to feel like they have to. And then
we're -- you know, then we've got a -- you
know, it's 1914 all over again with nuclear
weapons and the Middle East is the Balkans
of this century.
So this is a -- this is a really important
moment, and all the dynamics that are employed,
but the key thing is we're talking for the
first time in 10 years, 12 years, and in reality,
34 years, 35 years. And I just -- we can't
-- we just can't let this moment slip away.
I used to teach about the Cuban missile crisis,
and to me, the elements of the Cuban missile
crisis were four -- an existential threat,
a credible threat of force, some kind of sanction,
which was the quarantine, and negotiation.
Put those together and you can solve the problem.
And I think this situation is very similar.
And if it hadn't -- you know, if nobody -- anybody
studies the Cuban missile crisis, if they
hadn't kept talking, you know, it would have
been a disaster, you know, there's no word
for it. Catastrophe is too mild a word. And
these moments come and go in history. And
we've got to seize this one, in my view -- not
naively or blindly or, you know, acquiescently,
if that's a word, but realistically, with
our eyes open, understanding the risks, and
understanding the importnace of verification.
BRENNAN: Question here in the front, and then
here on the side.
QUESTION: Allen Went (ph), formerly with the
State Department. Senator, in the past, we
have been concerned that IAEA inspection procedures
in Iran were simply inadequate to detect any
violation of Iran's commitments. What's different
this time that satisfies us that the inspection
procedures will be intrusive enough to detect
any Iranian violations?
KING: Well, I don't -- I don't have a specific
sort of intelligence-based answer to that,
except that we have a period to test that.
I mean, we're going to find out in a matter
of weeks how much access they have and how
often they can get in, what the monitoring
is going to be, what the real-time streaming
video monitoring is going to be, what facilities
they get to.
And I think this is a continuing process.
It's not now and in six months. I think it's
-- there's a -- it's a -- it's a process whereby
we can try to determine, A, the level of verification,
B, whether it's sufficiently rigorous, and
C, whether the Iranians are -- are playing
straight with us. And at any time along that
process, we'll be able to say, Wait a minute.
This isn't working.
So I can't tell you today that they have 42
inspectors where they used to have 24. I don't
know that. I do know that inspection is a
key part, maybe the most important part of
the interim agreement.
BRENNAN: Here on the side.
QUESTION: I'm Morton Halperin (ph) from the
Open Society Foundations. Senator, as you
know, the Armed Services Committee on which
you sit did a very important study of detainee
treatment, and then that report was released
and helped educate the American people. Now
the Intelligence Committee, on which you also
sit, has completed another report, and I wonder
whether you support declassifying and releasing
that report.
KING: I could give you the answer as of today.
Probably, but I'm still not fully convinced.
There were some limitations with the Intelligence
Committee. This is a study done of torture,
basically, and what -- what we did in the
early part of the century. There were some
limitations to that study. Nobody was interviewed.
It was all documentary. And you always get
a -- I'm not sure you get a fully accurate
picture when you're looking at documents and
don't -- don't do interviews with the individuals
involved.
I'm -- my judgment is going to be based upon
whether I think it's -- it will be helpful
to the country and to the dialogue. I've seen
it. I've read it -- not all 6,000 pages, but
I've read a good deal of the -- of the substance
of it. And my inclination is to vote to release
it, but I'm reserving judgment. I'm sure we're
going to have a vigorous debate in the -- in
the committee.
Unfortunately, as you may know, the committee
broke up on partisan lines, and the Republican
members essentially didn't -- they pulled
their staff back from participation. So it
wasn't a true joint report, which I think
is unfortunate.
So I'm going to -- I'm going to listen to
the debate. I realized a couple -- about two
months ago in an Intelligence Committee meeting,
I'm the deciding vote. There are 15 members.
There are 7 Democrats, 7 Republicans and me.
And we had an amendment on something, and
I voted no, and I realized I'd swayed -- you
know, I'd decided which way it went. That
was -- that was a little disconcerting. I
killed an amendment by Jay Rockefeller and
apologized, he said, That's all right.
(LAUGHTER)
So I am going to have a -- I take very seriously
this -- this vote, and it's one that I'm -- as
I say, I'm leaning toward yes, but I'm not
fully there yet. And the decision for me is,
will it -- will it contribute to the public
dialogue and understanding, or will it distort
it and not be an accurate picture. That's
-- that's where I am. Thank you for the question.
BRENNAN: We have time for probably two questions.
If you could keep them succinct, that'll help
us. Here in front.
QUESTION: Hi. I'm Stephen Colpack (ph) from
Lincolnville, Maine. I wanted to ask you...
KING: If you're from Lincolnville, Maine,
what the hell are you doing here?
(LAUGHTER)
QUESTION: I came -- I came to see...
KING: Lincolnville, Maine, is one of the most
beautiful places on earth.
QUESTION: I came to see you, Senator.
(LAUGHTER)
QUESTION: Totally different subject. You mentioned
that Senator Snowe stepped down because she
was frustrated by the partisan politics. We
were very proud to elect you as an independent
from Maine, and you talked about just now
your -- how that's actually come in handy
a couple of times. How's it going for you,
the bipartisanship?
(LAUGHTER)
KING: Well, first I should say I'm having
a great time. I mean, I just have to admit
that. It's frustrating at times, but I told
my wife a few weeks ago I've been preparing
for this job all my life, I just didn't know
it.
And it is frustrating. I mean, but there have
been opportunities where we've been able to
nudge people. And in fact, the highlight and
the lowlight of last year was the same time,
the shutdown. The low point was the shutdown.
It was so ridiculous, so avoidable, so predictable,
so you know, harmful. The highlight was we
formed this little group with Susan Collins,
14 of us, that actually negotiated a settlement.
It was bipartisan. We had 7 Republicans, 6
Democrats and me. And we negotiated a settlement,
and Susan went to Mitch McConnell and said,
We've got a deal, and if you and Harry don't
work this out and announce something by 3:00
this afternoon, we're having a press conference.
And lo and behold, they finalized their deal.
Now, I'm not prepared to take credit for it,
but I feel like we did make a contribution
to moving that process forward. And here's
something really interesting. After that happened
and it got out that we had this little group,
we started getting applicants to join. We
started hearing from other senators saying,
We'd like to join that group.
And in fact, we were supposed to have a meeting
this morning, but it's been postponed because
of an Armed Services Committee meeting. But
we're now going to tackle some of these issues
of amendments, of process, and work -- and
unemployment insurance as trying to work from
the center out.
If that works, it will have all been worth
it, even the $6 million they spent to try
to defeat me . And so you know, I feel -- it's
still a very partisan place, but the interesting
thing is it's not partisan personally. The
relationships are there. It's very positive
relationships. And so I'm feeling -- I'm fired
up. It's -- it's -- it's amazing.
And particularly for somebody who was there
as a staff member 40 years ago, I keep expecting
somebody to walk onto the floor of the United
States Senate and say, What the hell are you
doing here? You know? People say, Good morning,
Senator, and I do this. It's an amazing experience.
And I walk to work. I live east of the Capitol
and walk to work down Maryland Avenue, and
the sun is rising and lighting up the dome
of the Capitol, and to look up and see that
and say, That's where I get to go to work.
It's humbling. It's really an amazing opportunity.
So I'm -- I'm having a good time. Mostly.
My wife, if she were here, would say, He loves
it.
(LAUGHTER)
BRENNAN: Back of the room I think there was
a question. Here, can we run a mic?
QUESTION: Hello, everybody. (inaudible) from
Voice of America. Senator, some opponent of
Assad's regime claimed that the nuclear deal
with Iran caused America's silence against
Iran's assistance for the survival of Assad.
How...
KING: For the survival of what? I'm sorry.
BRENNAN: Assad.
QUESTION: Assad regime.
BRENNAN: Bashar al Assad.
QUESTION: How in your perspective nuclear
deal affect America's position towards Syria?
KING: I haven't -- I haven't seen that. Reporter
Margaret would be a better person to respond
because she just came back from Geneva, where
-- and was with Secretary Kerry. But I don't
-- I haven't heard of any talk of, Hey, we're
-- we're working on this nuclear deal, therefore
we're going to take the pressure off Assad.
I -- I -- now, you know, I'm not in these
meetings, but I have no knowledge of that
being the case. We want -- our policy is to
get Assad out, to have a transitional government
and to try to do something for the humanitarian
catastrophe that's taking place in that country.
I was there -- Carl Levin and I went in the
summer to Turkey and Jordan, to the refugee
camps, and it's -- it's an awful, awful situation.
And what the Assad regime does in terms of
how they -- their tactic of just bombing a
town down to rubble is inhumane in the extreme.
But I haven't -- in answer to your question,
I haven't seen any evidence that there's a
linkage, that somehow, behind the scenes,
the deal is, We'll do the nuclear thing if
you'll leave our guy, Assad, alone. If that's
what you're suggesting, I haven't seen any
evidence of that.
BRENNAN: So we've hit the witching hour here...
KING: Thank you.
BRENNAN: ... of 9:30. So I know there are
more questions, but we're going to have to
leave it there. Just to remind you all, this
was on the record and...
KING: Oh, I didn't know that!
(LAUGHTER)
BRENNAN: You didn't see me furiously scribbling
down notes?
(LAUGHTER)
BRENNAN: Thank you very much, Senator, for
your time.
KING: Thank you, Margaret. A real pleasure.
BRENNAN: Interesting conversation.
(APPLAUSE)